how does a buddy comedy movie differ
from a romantic comedy
they probably are not having sex
but uh in a buddy comedy
um they're getting intimate and it's
about learning how to get intimate in a
way that they haven't been intimate
before so
so the you know part of the part of the
comic Trope is you get them as close to
having sex as you can without making it
kind of this you know creepier graphic
but what's one of the classic comic
buddy comedies out there Planes Trains
and Automobiles and what's one of the
funniest sequences when they have to
sleep together
because it's about learning to
in a buddy comedy they have to learn to
drop defenses and and become more
intimate than they already have
if you start with a buddy like in
Wedding Crashers they seem like they're
great buddies but it's so superficial
because their goal is superficial to
just work together to seduce women at
weddings
but what happens after them is they both
get into
dilemmas they both find women that they
really like uh some of whom kind of
confuse them
um and they both have to help themselves
to resolve their problems so uh so a
good buddy movie is a movie in which uh
both characters need to change in some
way and and somehow this pairing
um either the pairing itself is the is
the inciting incident or something
happens to them that changes their
relationship and changes the way that
they react to each other and they react
to the World At Large the one thing I
want to say about
the difference between the Hero Journey
and the comic heroes journey I think one
of the important differences
is in the hero's journey the hero is
greatness Within
and is eventually going to heal the
world
the comic heroes Journey
the hero has to heal himself
or herself
the world's fine
or the world's not fine the world is the
way the world is
but the comic hero is not is not
integrated well into that world
and in whatever way that comic hero
exhibits his or her personality it's we
in the audience can see that's not
working for them
Bill Murray's a jerk and eventually
he'll be alone he'll be a jerk all by
himself
Steve Carell and 40 year old virgin he's
a nice guy but he's going to be alone
too neither one of those are really
going to work
Kristen Wiig and bridesmaids oh my God
you know I hope she can stop trying to
uh let Jon Hamm have his booty calls
so
so the world isn't changing
they have to change and I think the
lesson for us is that and we we can try
to change the world
but you know
changing ourselves uh is both more
immediate and and more to the point
what's the structure of a buddy comedy
whether it's buddy cop whether it's
groomsmen whether it's swingers with
John Favreau uh I I think I think the
structure is is still basically the same
you have the normal world how do they
normally get together how do they how
does this world work for them in in the
usual way then something happens to
change it
something something happens to to make
the normal
change and then it goes through the rest
I think then it goes through the rest of
the steps I'm not sure I have a a clever
or insightful answer to that because I
think it's I mean I could look at
individual movies and talk about how
their individual structures are
different but as a genre
um buddy movies are are uh structured
the same as other comedy movies with
with some impossible or improbable thing
uh happening that forces these
characters to change in the other guys
Will Ferrell and Mark Wahlberg uh are
the other guys they're they're the not
the hero cops they're not the cops who
can do anything and could you know solve
every crime and beat every band they're
the other guys and when the hero cops
are killed and they have to step up
that's the WTF that's is it impossible
no it's improbable that these two guys
so different have to work together to
you know solve the crime to to to you
know do what they need to do for the
police force so I think it's I think
it's structured fairly the same in terms
of normal World there they have they
have their fall their flaws their faults
and everything's going to stay the same
until
the inciting incident and then they have
to transform and as they transform they
begin to open up to each other and they
begin to learn new skills and they begin
to transform
so that
uh Will Ferrell becomes more heroic uh
and Mark Wahlberg becomes
um
a little smarter about what he does so
they they kind of learn from each other
that that happens in a lot of bunny
movies the the movie the the part of
that movie that I love so much is where
uh Will Ferrell introduces Mark uh to
his wife who's this gorgeous supermodel
and and all Mark Wahlberg couldn't say
is come on you're kidding right or yeah
because he he can't he can't understand
it so I thought that was very funny
what should a writer know before
beginning a buddy comedy movie
I think he needs to know how these two
characters
complement each other
and antagonize each other
I think that's I mean that that's one
thing they need to know is that is that
you're putting two characters
um in a situation that they're both
uncomfortable with
both maybe the situation itself or or
certainly each other and so
it can't just be antagonism
it's got to be a situation in which
as the narrative progresses
the
the one character one character has to
have something to offer to the other
character
the other character has to have
something to offer to the first
character it can't be one way
um
in in 48 hours uh you know Nick Nolte is
this can do it cop but you know Eddie
Murphy has some has some chops too and
and he can
add to what Nick Nolte can do because
Eddie Murphy has has his his humor his
cleverness his his improvisational
skills his ability to to kind of take
advantage of any kind of situation
um and Nick Nolte is this big bull of a
guy so they have to you have to figure
out what do they need to learn and can
they learn from each other it's not just
enough to have
um a tall guy and a short guy a fat guy
and a skinny guy uh the Buddy comedy has
to explore
what does it mean to
be intimate with another person and to
learn from another person
and if you take the female sort of
Flipside like Two Broke Girls
that even though that's a TV show that
they they were still able to they didn't
really seem to get under each other's
skin as much right they they were in
this together right but they have to get
in into each other's skin to a certain
extent
I mean The Odd Couple they certainly get
you know that was a play that had that
had you know a beginning you know a WTF
and then it it they they start to hate
each other there's a big fight but then
they learned that they needed each other
because they're both divorced guys and
they yeah they need they need the
friendship
so so it's it's it's about
I think the thing that you have to do is
is sometimes when you write a buddy
comedy you're saying well that's the
dumb guy or that's the loser guy and you
condescend to that character you write
down to that character and you have to
remember
you know what if what if you're the
loser guy
you know so so you have to realize that
that they both have something to offer
each other and then in the beginning
they don't know that
hey and that's great too even if this is
not this is more romantic comedy but
with the Bridget Jones Diary Renee
Zellweger's character is is is not a bad
person but she's always fumbling and you
know pantyhose dressing the pantyhose
kind of a thing and and you
it's hard to look down on her because
she's still lovable right I mean they
design it that way but she's still
someone that you want to embrace and
you'd want to be friends right but but
it's not her fault that she and that she
goes to the party in a in a buddy suit
somebody somebody set her up sir but but
what's lovely about her is she tries to
make the best of it